et un club spécial consacré évidemment à
l'examen de la réforme des retraites au
Sénat les sénateurs qui ont donc voté
cette nuit l'article 7 sur le report de
l'âge légal de départ à 64 ans pour en
débattre avec nous deux sénateurs
Guillaume Gontard bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous sénateurs de l'Isère ou
président le groupe écologiste ici au
Sénat et Xavier yaccovénie bonjour c'est
Nathan des Hauts-de-Seine vice-président
du groupe Renaissance RDPI Renaissance
le groupe des sénateurs de la majorité
présidentielle on va évidemment
commencer en parlant de cet article 7
c'est la formation de la nuit Audrey il
a été adopté par le Sénat oui l'article
sent lequel la réforme n'existerait pas
et qui n'avait pas été étudié en s'en
souvient à l'Assemblée nationale article
adopté donc après minuit 201 voies pour
115 voix contre et une trentaine
d'abstention notamment chez les
centristes et chez les LR l'avantage du
scrutin public c'est qu'on a un vote
très détaillé donc quand on regarde les
voix contre 115 c'est plus que les 91
voies de la gauche Oriane les amis sont
donc plus partagés que le simple clivage
gauche-droite et puis ce qu'on est dans
le détail du il faut souligner aussi
qu'il y a eu deux abstentions dans votre
groupe le groupe de la majorité
présidentielle deux abstentions merci
Audrey vous le vivez comme une défaite
ce qui s'est passé cette nuit au cinéma
certainement pas comme une certaine pas
commune des fêtes par contre comme un
jour triste grave pour les Françaises et
les Français parce que c'est un recul
c'est un recul sans précédent je crois
que c'est Pierre Mauroy qui disait qu'on
a pas le droit d'abolir l'histoire et
c'est un petit peu ce qui vient de se
faire c'est à dire des années et des
années de lutte sociale sur la réduction
du temps de travail
on a eu la retraite à 60 ans 62
maintenant on passe à 64 ans jusqu'où on
va aller voilà je dirais le seul
objectif que nous propose ce
gouvernement mais on voit bien que ça
avance on a un vote qui est loin d'être
unanime du côté de du côté de la droite
pourtant on a un très bon ambassadeur
d'Emmanuel Macron avec Bruno Retailleau
on voit que même ne le suivent pas on
voit que dans le
majorités
qu'on est deux abstentions d'ailleurs je
sais pas Paris a priori on nous disait
que ceux qui ne voteraient pas dans le
sens serait exclu je ne sais pas comment
du coup vous allez Admiral ici ah
d'accord il y a des différences je
pensais que c'était votre
donc voilà moi je pense que ça avance et
puis il y a la mobilisation une
mobilisation sans précédent et qui ne
faiblit pas qui continue parce que les
Françaises et les Français tout
simplement ne veulent pas de je dirais
de ces solutions quelque part simpliste
mais qui ont un impact sur la vie des
gens terribles je vous laisse répondre
mais juste pas d'exclusion des deux
sénateurs qui ont voté contre il est pas
question d'avoir d'exclusion aujourd'hui
ils se sont abstenus il y a une
dimension personnelle aussi qui joue
dans dans cette position mais je pense
que c'était important aujourd'hui de
passer cette étape de l'article 7 je
vous laisse répondre au contact qui dit
que ce gouvernement aboli histoire non
mais déjà répondre il y a pas de
victoire ou pas de défaite sur cet
article 7 déjà je pense que c'est une
victoire pour le Sénat dans son ensemble
et pour la démocratie parce qu'on a
réussi à avoir un vote enfin c'est ce
qui est quand même elle sait
hallucinante d'être obligée de de le
rappeler enfin le Parlement le Parlement
est là pour voter on avait un petit peu
oublié avec ce qui se passe à
l'Assemblée nationale et avec peut-être
des positions d'ailleurs qui sont les
vôtres monsieur le président de groupe
vous assumez clairement de ne pas
vouloir voter ce qui est quand même
particulier pour un parlementaire mais
jamais avoir dit ça mais si vous
retrouvez quelque chose vous vous avez
clairement assumé dans l'hémicycle de ne
pas vouloir aller jusqu'au bout du texte
donc c'est à dire de ne pas voter
pardonnez-moi alors
moi j'ai dit que je voulais j'ai
toujours voulu aller au bout et faire le
débat bah vous m'interpeller donc oui
pour le coup je vous ai pas répondu et
donc oui donc c'est ce que vous avez
aussi mais aussi en réunion des
présidents de groupe et c'est tout à
fait votre point de vue moi je pense que
c'est aujourd'hui une attaque
effectivement contre la démocratie et
contre notre Parlement de ne pas donner
la possibilité aux chambres respectives
de pouvoir s'exprimer on a vu à
l'Assemblée nationale qu'on avait pas pu
aller jusqu'au bout même pas aller plus
loin que l'article 2 aujourd'hui nous
sommes à l'article 7 voté au Sénat on va
pouvoir désormais maintenant regarder
les autres articles qui sont sur la
question de la pénibilité les départs
anticipés sur l'usure professionnelle
les mesures de retraite progressive les
mesures d'Alpha on a un certain nombre
de mesures sociales et d'accompagnement
qui sont très importantes pour les
Français et qu'on va pouvoir enfin
maintenant travailler après le passage
de cet article on va y venir et sur
l'ambiance mais sur cette article 7 qui
a donc été voté premier vote à au
Parlement du coup sur cet article 7 il y
a une forme de soulagement quand même
chez vous
c'est pas une question de soulagement
encore une fois c'est une étape qui
était indispensable pour l'équilibre
financier de cette réforme et surtout
pour la pérennisation de notre système
de retraite par répartition encore une
fois on n'est pas là pour se faire
plaisir et pour dire qu'on a une
victoire ou on est heureux de faire
travailler deux ans de plus les Français
et encore une fois ce n'est pas deux ans
de plus pour tout le monde il y a 40 %
des Français qui n'auront pas à aller
jusqu'à l'âge légal parce qu'il y a des
mesures d'accompagnement il y a des
mesures de pénibilité d'usure
professionnelle de départ anticipé de
trimestre supplémentaire pour les
aidants qui vont permettre à un certain
nombre de Français 40% de français de
partir par anticipation grâce à cette
réforme
je voulais déjà revenir parce que ce
petit discours blocage ou en empêcherait
le débat franchement on a démarré un
texte avec 3000 amendements 3000
amendements pour un texte comme ça
global sur l'ensemble comme ça me paraît
effectivement c'était pas des
amendements RDP en tout cas en marche
parce que voilà mais par contre on avait
à peu près sur ces 3000 à peu près plus
de 1000 amendements qui sont
issus des rangs de la droite ce qui est
une très bonne chose voilà nous on a
déposé l'ensemble de la gauche à peu
près 2000 amendements donc on est quand
même très loin du blocus on a des
amendements sur l'ensemble des articles
on en a encore beaucoup donc au
contraire évidemment qu'on veut le débat
évidemment qu'on veut le dépasser vous
qui depuis le début esquiver ce débat
c'est vous qui on a vu la séquence qui a
pu se passer alors on a ce véhicule
législatif parce qu'on veut réduire le
temps pourquoi réduire le temps on a le
temps de débattre je pense que les
Français doivent entendre ce qu'on a à
dire on doit pouvoir porter la parole
des Français je pense que vous prenez
une responsabilité très forte je vois
ces images de gens qui sont qui sont
dans la rue
qu'est-ce qu'on est nous parlementaire
on est le relais de ces gens ceux qui
sont dans la rue pour vous ce qui ne le
sont pas mais on est le relais et si on
coupe ce relais si on coupe ce débat
parlementaire je pense que c'est très
grave pour notre démocratie et pour
l'image de la politique donc ce que vous
êtes en train de faire avec Bruno
Retailleau avec Gérard Larcher pour moi
et très grave parce que non le Parlement
c'est là où on discute c'est là où on
échange et c'est là où on construit et
c'est là où on construit la loi hier
soir hier soir on a déposé un certain
nombre d'amendements il y a eu quatre ou
cinq amendements qui sont passés parce
que oui quand on regarde de près on se
dit ah bah oui pour les sportifs c'est
vrai que ça va être compliqué de de
passer à 64 ans hop pour les pompiers ah
bah oui aussi donc on voit que quand on
regarde de près c'est une réforme ne
tient pas et donc heureusement qu'on
fait ce travail parlementaire et moi je
suis fier de le faire et oui j'irai
jusqu'à dimanche minuit
donc vous vous acceptez de vouloir aller
jusqu'au vote final de dimanche minuit
mais j'accepte rien du tout mais à
dimanche qui justifie
pardonnez-moi mais en fait
vous avez assumé le fait que le
Parlement était là effectivement pour
débattre je l'affirme améliorer et ça on
est d'accord là dessus j'affirme aussi
que le gouvernement donc je vous laisse
voilà j'affirme que le gouvernement a
limité à dimanche minuit donc si je peux
me permettre si je peux me permettre
pardonnez-moi mais donc le Parlement est
là pour débattre pour améliorer un texte
pour amender et infiner pour voter c'est
le principe même du Parlement sinon on
ne sert à rien pardonnez-moi on ne vote
pas des lois je ne veux pas on peut pas
nous vous rappeler monsieur le Président
parce que j'avais cru comprendre que
encore une fois le groupe écologiste et
une partie de grande la grande majorité
des députés enfin des sénateurs pardon
de la nuque oui je m'en je m'y perds
puisque Jean-Luc Mélenchon a même salué
les sénateurs de la nuque qui faisait
obstruction au texte donc on voit bien
que il y a effectivement ça vous pose
problème enfin je veux dire ah bah oui
moi j'ai pas j'ai pas besoin d'avoir un
mentor
Emmanuel Macron qui d'ailleurs on entend
pas trop au dessus vous devez suivre le
train c'est de s'écouter et de pouvoir
répondre à des interpellations
donc la prochaine fois vous serez invité
au Matinal tout seul comme ça vous aurez
pas de question à répondre moi ce que je
pensais effectivement c'est important
d'aller jusqu'au bout du texte pour nous
exprimer moi je suis d'accord il y a
hier il y a eu des amendements de fond
où on a pu trouver une lunanimité sur
des amendements mais moi quand je vois
effectivement le début du texte les
parce que moi j'ai fait les 7 jours
quand on voit effectivement le début du
texte où on a des renvois d'émotions de
renvoi en commission parce qu'on estime
que le travail n'a pas été
fait pardon en commission il y a pas de
souci motion de renvoi mais les mêmes
qui déposent l'émotions de renvoi en
commission en commission refuse de
débattre en disant ça se jouera dans
l'hémicycle donc si c'est pas de
l'obstruction le fait de multiplier les
prises de parole les amendements
identiques du même groupe de la même
personne
c'est clairement de l'instruction c'est
le premier texte où au fur et à mesure
de l'examen des amendements et des
articles on a plus d'amendements que ce
que quand on a commencé c'est quand même
particulier parce qu'il y a des sous un
œuf qui arrive au fur et à mesure donc
vous assumé une obstruction c'est pas
mais après assumez
je n'assume pas
d'obstructions
et une obstruction silencieuse de la
droite il y a plus ensuite une autre
solution de départ ensuite si vous
voulez
le Président si vous voulez qu'on
débattre sur les amendements de fond
retirez vos amendements d'obstruction et
on pourra avoir un vrai débat de qualité
comme c'est le cas l'article 48 la
sagesse 42 et là laissez-nous débattre
comme on a toujours
on arrive justement à débattre
d'habitude correctement sur le fond vous
avez raison de vraiment
si vous êtes contre la réforme et si
vous êtes contre les mesures sociales
qui vont arriver à partir d'aujourd'hui
vous pourrez assumer vous voit par un
vote mais c'est possible de la
démocratie
et vous verrez et c'est pour ça tu m'as
parlementaire et c'est pour ça qu'on a
besoin de temps pour se débat par le
commentaire nous on a aucun problème
pour défendre nos idées on n'a pas peur
de nos idées on n'a pas besoin de
contraintes par multiple artifices et la
première fois qu'on utilise un article
42 au Sénat l'article 38 je crois a été
utilisé une fois pourquoi sur ce texte
pourquoi sur ce texte quoi sur ce texte
où il y a pourquoi sur ce texte où il y
a 3000 amendements et où est
l'obstruction on a on a débattu la
moitié du temps on est à l'article 7 qui
est la moitié du texte où est
l'obstruction oui on avance on avance à
un rythme on a des amendements on les
débats vous reprochez d'avoir eu un
certain nombre d'abandonnements
effectivement qu'il se ressemblent et
d'avoir
sénateur sénatrice qui ont pris la
parole sur cet article 7 mais
heureusement moi je trouve que je suis
étonné qui est pas eu l'ensemble des
sénatrices et des sénateurs qui n'est
pas pris la parole sur ce texte
représentants des territoires on est sur
le territoire
et pour la première fois il y a eu des
manifestations il y a des gens qui sont
allés dans la rue on n'avait jamais vu
ça vous rendez compte je je comprendrais
pas que un sénatrice ou un sénateur ne
prennent pas la parole et ne porte pas
la parole de ces gens heureusement et
c'est pour ça qu'il y a un parlement et
vous êtes en train de dévoyer ça mais
non justement le dévoiement du Parlement
c'est ne pas voter et de ne pas amender
on a fait que
[Musique]
pétrole et qui ont donné la position du
groupe sur des différents amendements et
les différents articles entre l'article
1 de l'article luminaire et l'article 7
il y a des effectivement des éléments on
a des discussions à l'intérieur des
groupes il y a des positions qui peuvent
différer d'ailleurs entre certains
groupes on l'a vu d'ailleurs dans le
dans les différents votes qui se sont
succédés il y a des vrais amendements de
fonds qui ont été maintenus recevable et
qui ont pu être défendus et pas
quasiment même voté à l'unanimité sur un
certain nombre de mesures et c'est dans
ça va donc on est là où est le problème
mais le problème maintenant mais moi
j'ai moi il y a pas de souci si on se
dit
collectivement qu'à partir de maintenant
à partir de l'article 8 on va enfin
travailler sur des éléments de fonds
pour qu'on peu importe mais moi je
travaillais sur des éléments
ici l'article 7 n'est pas un élément de
fondation de 62 à 64 ans n'est pas bon
monsieur le Président on n'est pas
travailler sur le fonds
liminaire il y a pas de souci on ira
jusqu'au bout
un amendement on assumera des positions
qui seront certainement différentes mais
qui sont le propre de la démocratie vous
allez reprendre la parole et vous allez
un petit peu expliquer ce que vous ce
que vous pensez de ce texte et vos
arguments je pense que je pense qu'on le
dit régulièrement ah ben en fait jusqu'à
présent parce que vous êtes pas souvent
en séance c'est peut-être pour ça
monsieur le président
on a on a assumé à chaque fois nos
positions sur tous les textes sur tous
les amendements et surtout les articles
mais de toute façon vous êtes libre il y
a aucun souci donc chacun aborde le
débat parlementaire comme il le souhaite
voilà
un problème je n'assume absolument pas
l'obstruction parlementaire elle est de
votre côté c'est Gérard Larcher qui a
déclenché ses différents dispositifs et
justement c'est la première ministre qui
a décidé de de ce véhicule législatif
qui a débloqué le temps c'est la
première ministre qui a décidé le 47 ans
donc l'obstruction elle est certainement
pas de l'autre côté on va y venir
justement puisque la droite
justifie elle l'utilisation de cet
article 38 Audrey que vous allez un
petit peu nous expliquer alors je vous
explique très rapidement on a un peu
stratégie qui s'affrontent d'un côté la
majorité sénatoriale de droite qui veut
étudier le texte dans son intégralité
pour arriver à un vote final et être en
position de force parce qu'après
deux droites et c'est vrai qu'ils l'ont
beaucoup beaucoup rappelé
majorité sénatoriale qui voudrait bien
que ce soit le texte du Sénat qui arrive
en commission mixte paritaire c'est
après l'examen au Sénat vous savez c'est
cette réunion qui doit plancher sur le
texte final et puis d'un côté de l'autre
côté on a la gauche opposé à la réforme
qui utilise finalement les armes qu'elle
a pour ralentir le débat car le texte
vous savez s'il n'a pas été voté à
l'Assemblée nationale s'il n'est pas
voté non plus par le Sénat il est de
fait affaibli paroxysme donc ces
derniers jours on va peut-être en
reparler pour accélérer les débats à la
droite a fait une sorte de coupe
politique à la réécrit dans la nuit du 7
au 8 l'article 7 qui a eu pour
conséquence de faire tomber un millier
de vos amendements les amendements de la
gauche la gauche qui a sans tenté de
sous-amender le texte mais qui s'est
heurté un refus de la commission des
affaires sociales autre coup
d'accélérateur la droite et la majorité
présidentielle ont utilisé à plusieurs
reprises l'article 38 du Règlement du
Sénat une arme pour les téléspectateurs
qui permet de limiter je résume
drastiquement les prises de parole sur
un amendement alors évidemment la droite
qu'il a utilisé ce justifie on va
écouter les explications de Bruno
Retailleau le président du groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
avant qu'hier soir dans la nuit
cet article 38 qui est sorti par Bruno
retaillod après des manifestations sans
précédent historique dans un hémicycle
qui a été en train de débattre alors je
le note d'ailleurs en pleine nuit bah
voilà on a décidé que maintenant c'était
fini qu'on allait réduire le temps de
parole de l'opposition ben non c'est pas
acceptable donc oui effectivement on a
des moyens qu'on a on nous explique que
les moyens qui sont utilisés sont des
moyens démocratiques on utilise aussi
des moyens démocratiques pour essayer de
faire entendre nos voix mais l'inverse
ne serait pas ne serait pas entendu et
je et je dirais que les trois présidents
de groupe Eliane assassy Patrick Kanner
moi-même on a interpellé quand on est
parti de l'hémicycle on a interpellé
solennellement l'ensemble je dirais de
la majorité parce que effectivement vous
avez raison de le rappeler et de le dire
il y a plus qu'une seule majorité on a
un représentant d'Emmanuel Macron avec
Bruno retaillod on a interpellé cette
majorité et le président Larcher pour
leur dire toute responsabilité qui vous
avez et qu'ils avaient encore la
possibilité de faire en sorte qu'on ait
un débat qui se déroule comme il s'est
déroulé jusqu'à l'article 7 voilà où est
nous la responsabilité elle est dans
leur camp parce que le temps n'est pas
compté maintenant qui est ce que c'est
la gauche qui a voulu attendre la
manifestation du 7 mars pour examiner
l'article 7 comment ça attendre moi il
me semble qu'on a débattu trouvez-moi un
élément dans le débat jusqu'à l'article
7 qui n'était pas nécessaire au
contraire moi j'ai même enfin on a tous
appris des choses et d'ailleurs j'ai
noté que je crois que c'était le
ministre hier soir qu'il le disait que
ce débat était riche qu'on apprenait des
choses qu'on pouvait échanger évidemment
donc il y a pas eu on attend l'article
on attend on attend les manifestations
on a débattu sur un texte et d'ailleurs
je me demande pourquoi vous vous faites
du souci vous tout le monde nous dit on
arrivera toute façon dimanche voilà il y
a pas de problème alors des bâtons et on
a pas besoin de de l'ensemble de ces
artifices et puis le gouvernement a la
possibilité si il nous manque une
journée si nous manque de journée on est
disponible on est disponible on peut
aller plus loin pour étudier l'ensemble
de ce texte donc voilà nous on est
parlementaires on est à disposition du
Parlement oui je pense qu'il faut qu'on
arrête de
d'être dans l'hypocrisie monsieur le
Président vous le savez très bien il y a
eu un accord de principe avec les
différents groupes qui composent le
Sénat pour le principe à votre à votre
demande d'ailleurs pour que nous
puissions aborder l'article 7
c'est-à-dire le prolongement de deux ans
de l'âge de la retraite comment on fait
pour
expliquer de ne pas justement utiliser
les éléments du règlement intérieur et
ceux de la Constitution pour accélérer
les débats et de nous laisser le débat
jusqu'au 7 jusqu'aux manifestations et
voilà c'était un accord avec les
différents groupes de je sais pas ce que
vous avez pas passé d'accord vous êtes
vous êtes
précisé possible de placer une phrase en
fait non mais c'est parce que le respect
entre les parlementaires c'est de
s'écouter aussi de ne pas être d'accord
forcément mais de s'écouter arrêter de
dire ce que je dois faire vous pouvez
parler
effectivement avec entre la majorité
sénatoriale le gouverne enfin pas le
gouvernement c'est grave c'est grave ce
que vous dites parce que un accord ça
veut dire qu'il y a un papier il y a des
choses signées il y a des réalités
tout le monde le dit parce que moi il y
a pas eu d'accord qui a pas eu d'accord
donc peut-être que vous étiez le seul
moi opposé qu'un accord avec son
occurrence il y avait un accord de
principe de pouvoir avoir ces débats
maintenant mais je je dis depuis tout à
l'heure un accord de principe en fait un
accord de principe effectivement aborder
l'article 7 à partir du 7 après les
manifestations et donc de laisser le
débat à partir du moment où
effectivement il y a eu tous ces débats
c'est ces éléments d'obstruction et qui
ont été assumés par les garçons de la
gauche c'est multiplication de sous
amendements amendement effectivement on
a souhaité maintenant arriver sur un
débat de fond et donc nous permettre
d'avancer sur ce texte sur des mesures
qui sont importantes pour les Français
d'accompagnement social c'est 6
milliards d'accompagnement et de mesures
sociales supplémentaires pour pour ce
texte et donc oui on a utilisé un
certain nombre d'articles que nous
confère la constitution et le règlement
du Sénat l'article 38 en fait partie et
donc ce sont des éléments qui nous
permettent maintenant d'avancer et de
travailler sur le fond je pense que
c'est ça aussi que les Français
attendent de nous c'est qu'on se
positionne pour ou contre ça c'est une
c'est le choix de chaque parti politique
et de chaque groupe politique mais
responsable des représentants de la
nation qui puissent se positionner et
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas seulement dans
les paroles qu'on se positionne c'est
aussi dans les votes est-ce que ce vote
de cette nuit risque de radicaliser la
contestation sociale je ne sais pas je
ne mesure pas forcément comme dit
Olivier du socle la météo sociale il y a
le temps du mouvement social il y a le
temps et il y a le temps parlementaire
le temps parlementaire où nous sommes en
plein dedans nous avons effectivement
jusqu'à dimanche minuit pour élaborer ce
texte pour l'améliorer moi je souhaite
qu'il y ait un certain nombre de mesures
et nous portons un certain nombre
d'amendements avec le groupe RDPI
majorité présidentielle un certain
nombre d'amendements d'amélioration de
ce texte il y aura ensuite le débat et
le travail avec l'Assemblée nationale en
commission mixte paritaire et nous nous
aurons nous continuons ce travail
parlementaire c'est notre rôle en tout
cas de représentants de la nation non
mais je confirme c'est quand même en
matière de de climat de prévision et de
météo vous n'êtes pas très fort parce
que ça soit sur effectivement le climat
social sur l'urgence je rappelle les
mots d'Olivier Véran on a
des sujets beaucoup plus importants à
traiter et ça pour le coup je suis
d'accord avec lui sur la question
climatique sur la question énergétique
sur la question du pouvoir d'achat
qu'est-ce qu'on est en train de faire
vos amis allemands
alors du coup vous me coupez aussi la
parole ah bah ok c'est pour savoir je
prends l'habitude mais moi ça me dérange
pas parce que je sais je sais répondre
et j'aime bien le dialogue en tout cas
sur sur ces sujets si importants là on
est en train de débattre d'un texte dont
on sait qu'il n'y avait aucune urgence
qui est une lubie du président de la
République
on peut refaire le débat sur sur ce que
peut dire le Conseil d'orientation des
des retraites oui oui on peut on peut le
refaire tout le monde le dit tout le
monde le sait qu'il n'y a aucune urgence
on sait pourquoi ce texte là que c'est
aussi une manière de faire ce grand
rassemblement avec les républicains donc
voilà où on en est moi j'attends du
gouvernement qu'il s'occupe des vrais
problèmes
je vois pas déranger quand ce grand
rassemblement se faisait de la majorité
présidentielle avec d'ailleurs une
grande partie décentrices et jusqu'à la
gauche quand il a fallu voter la
constitution de l'IVG il y a ce grand
rassemblement nous vous a pas dérangé
quand il a fallu un cheval quand il a
fallu contrer effectivement des
propositions de Bruno Retailleau sur la
question de du RSA ça ne vous a pas
dérangé qu'on se retrouve tous dans le
même camp pour protéger les acquis donc
vous voyez moi j'ai tout à fait la
capacité de ce président
liberté
les majorités elles se font sur ces des
idées elles se font sur des projets
elles ne se sont pas sur des postures et
ben là pour le coup à la majorité à la
majorité présidentielle et c'est la
raison pour laquelle inventé l'histoire
il n'y a pas de majorité présidentielle
avec la majorité présidentielle avec la
majorité sénatoriale il y a une majorité
sénatoriale et il y a la majorité
présidentielle qui est minoritaire et
qui est dans l'opposition sénatoriale
nous nous positionnons effectivement
texte sur des éléments qui disparaît
être important et aujourd'hui
effectivement nous avons trouvé un
accord et qui n'est pas encore abouti
avec la majorité sénatoriale pour
travailler sur ce point d'accord c'est
vrai que
en fait
c'était pour ça un accord oui sur le
principe on est d'accord sur le principe
d'allongement de la durée et des mesures
sociales
avec vous d'accord avec vous sur la
question du RSA nous nous pensons que
les projets primes sur les projets
d'accord avec nous survivés j'ai quand
même enfin je veux dire ça serait
l'inverse aurait été quand même assez
exceptionnel quand même mais donc ce qui
prouve que on peut dire que c'était dans
le programme d'Emmanuel Macron donc nous
ce qu'on attend maintenant sur des
projets dans l'avant ce qui fasse
réellement ce projet monsieur le
Président on est d'accord sur les
projets et nous c'est ce qui nous
importe c'est ce qui nous apporte c'est
les projets et pas les postures on va
revenir sur ce qui va se passer
aujourd'hui à priori vous allez débuter
l'examen de l'article 8 Audrey qu'est-ce
qu'il y a dans cet article 8 alors il
concerne le renforcement des départs
anticipés autorise la modification du
dispositif par voie réglementaire
notamment mais pas uniquement pour les
carrières longues on se souvient que
c'est sur la question des carrières
longues que la droite s'est divisée à
l'Assemblée nationale entre Aurélien
Pradier et ses soutiens et le reste des
LR ça aussi donné lieu à des concessions
de la première ministre à l'Assemblée la
dernière je la rappelle les salariés du
dispositif des carrières longues
n'auront pas à cotisé plus de 43 ans
pour partir à la retraite dès lors
qu'ils auront atteint l'âge de départ
anticipé requis et justement dans cet
article tu as également la question de
la surcotte pour les maires de famille
que vous allez voter vous avez la
comédie nous pensons effectivement que
nous allons voter cette proposition de
surcotte à partir de 63 ans pour les
femmes qui ont 43 années
les invités nécessaires pour arriver et
donc ne pas leur les obliger à aller
jusqu'à 64 ans mais enfin de leur
permettre de partir jusqu'à 64 ans mais
avec une surcoche justement à partir de
et notamment de Bruno retaillod c'est à
dire que le problème des retraites ça
serait quelque part les femmes parce que
on ne fait pas assez d'enfants et donc
il faudrait faire plus d'enfants et le
problème de retraite serait réglé cher
c'est pas comme ça qu'on règle qu'on
règle ces problèmes
les femmes font des enfants si elles le
souhaitent et donc il faut revenir à
cette liberté moi je fais pas de
différence entre des femmes qui font des
enfants qui n'en sont pas et donc on
voit bien toutes je dirais l'absurdité
de de ce texte et que effectivement
quand on le prend par le petit bout de
la lorgnette on arrive à ce type de
dispositif non on a non non et on a on a
on a on le on le sait d'autres moyens de
financer parce que c'est quand même ça
le fond c'est qu'on essaie de nous
emmener sur comme s'il y avait qu'une
seule ligne hein c'était la réforme ou
la faillite il y a pas d'autres
solutions il faut faire comme ça c'est
passé de 62 à 64 ans c'est de faire plus
d'enfants voilà c'est il y a pas
d'autres possibilités il y a pas d'autre
solution on sait très bien qu'on peut
financer d'une autre manière sur la
question de la participation du du
capital ça paraît important on a fait le
fond de réserve des retraites comment on
alimente ce fond de réserve des
retraites qui a été siphonné et qui
signale pas siphonner pas monsieur
Fillon par Monsieur verte aujourd'hui on
n'aurait pas de problème de financement
des retraites donc oui il y a des
solutions oui effectivement il y a des
solutions mais que nous nous souhaitons
pas emprunter et on l'assume depuis
c'est-à-dire de ne pas augmenter les
impôts sur les Français et au contraire
moi depuis 2017 on baisse cette pression
une sur les milliardaires c'est super
pression fiscales sur les Français et
donc oui vous assumez aujourd'hui de
vouloir faire des taxes et des impôts
supplémentaires sur les français pour
financer un système mais il y a pas de
souci c'est un modèle de société qui
n'est pas qui n'est pas le nôtre nous
nous estimons effectivement que c'est
super profit j'assume effectivement de
faire participer le président
pardonnez-moi mais en fait on a voté une
taxe sur les super profits sur les
énergéticiens qui rapportent 11
milliards 11 milliards c'est ce que nous
avons fait avec Gabriel attend du coup
on a pas de souci parce que en fait nous
on part du principe que le système va
répartition en fait c'est notre système
vous savez c'est ce qu'on a hérité un
système de répartition
un dernier mot juste le système de
retraite par répartition ce sont les
actifs qui financent les retraites les
pensions de retraite et donc à partir du
moment où on crée un impôt dire indirect
sur pour financer un système qui est
foncièrement et structurellement
déficitaire nous sortons de ce système
par répartition et là vous faites le jeu
de la droite
vous faites le jeu de la droite parce
que justement là vous permettez à la
droite de partir sur la capitalisation
et je crois que ça ne passe que nous
voulons la majorité présidentielle de la
droite quand même ça serait dommage et
ce sera le mot de la fin merci messieurs
vous restez avec nous on va continuer à
parler de cette réforme des retraites
challenge de nos quotidien régional
[Musique]
et Audrey réforme des retraites
mouvements syndical à la une de nos
quotidiens régionaux oui blocage grève
manif c'est parti pour durer nous
prévient le progrès le succès de la
mobilisation de mardi à donner de l'élan
aux actions qui devraient se multiplier
dans les prochains jours le Courrier
Picard nous raconte et souligne que les
syndicats se heurtent toujours à un
silence d'Emmanuel Macron la porte de
l'Elysée reste fermée titre le quotidien
alors certains déploient les grands
moyens s'étant une de l'art de lait à
Charleville-Mézières la Fédération CGT
de l'énergie à procéder lundi à des
coupures de gaz et l'électricité plus de
8000 foyers ont été touchés les remises
en service sont en cours c'est dans ce
contexte que Laurent Berger le patron de
la CFDT a répondu aux questions de
Presse Océan dans son fief à
Saint-Nazaire lui aussi attend des
signes de l'exécutif il évoque une crise
démocratique les mots sont forts et
dénoncent un silence face à un mouvement
social inédit depuis les années 90
au lendemain de la journée des droits
des femmes de nombreux quotidiens
consacrent leur une aux violences dont
elles sont victimes et j'ai choisi celle
du Républicain Lorrain qui évoque
l'histoire d'une femme poignardée à Metz
en pleine rue hier au moment de la
journée internationale pour la lutte
pour les droits des femmes par son
ex-compagnant elle a été hospitalisée
dans un état grave un fait divers qui
nous rappelle que la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes est un
combat de chaque instant Oriane le
quotidien rappelle d'ailleurs le numéro
pour le numéro de soutien et
d'orientation des femmes le 39 19 que je
relai ici Jean Castex réfute la
vengeance d'État dans l'affaire d'humeur
colonne Corse-Matin nous apprend que
l'ancien Premier ministre était
auditionné hier par la commission
d'enquête parlementaire qui doit faire à
la lumière sur les dysfonctionnements
qui ont conduit au meurtre du militant
indépendantiste Jean cassette qui a
réputé toute idée de manœuvre de la part
de l'État dans l'instruction du dossier
Colonna et notamment en ce qui concerne
le rejet de levée de statut de détenus
particulièrement
signalé pardon on s'en souvient divan
Colonna et puis je termine par un grand
bol d'air frais je vous en mettre chez
moi Oriane
du Dauphiné Libéré un bol d'air frais
mais sans neige notamment à
saint-pierre-en-chartreuse la station
qui se réinvente station à peu près 2000
mètres d'altitude qui doit se réinventer
le ski l'hiver dans ces stations ça
devient compliqué un dossier à lire en
ligne du Dauphiné Libéré voilà terminé
avec une image de chez vous deux parce
que vous êtes du même endroit
merci beaucoup Audrey on se retrouve
évidemment demain et puis vous suivrez
toute la journée l'examen de cette
réforme des retraites au Sénat éditeurs
vous avez enlevé Thomas public très
bonne journée à demain
[Musique]